字幕: Mai Iida
校正: Toko Takao
皆さんのふるさとは どんなところですか
そしてそこに何があるのか 本当に知っていますか
宮城県亘理町 仙台から電車で南に40分
人口約3万人の 小さな城下町
真っ赤で甘いイチゴの産地です
私はこの町で生まれ育ちました
仙台の高校に通うようになって
大きな建物や素敵なお店がたくさんあるのに驚いて
「亘理って田舎だったんだぁ」って知りました
一生懸命標準語で話しても
隠しきれない訛りが出ちゃって
本名じゃなくて「亘理ちゃん」なんて
呼ばれちゃったりして
亘理のことも自分のことも
なんだかあか抜けなくてかっこ悪くて
あまり好きじゃありませんでした
2011年2月 私は町役場の職員でした
郷土資料館に務めていて
学芸員として民俗調査に携わり
着物というテーマで 古い時代の亘理を知る人たちを
訪ね歩いていました
80過ぎのおばあちゃんがタンスを開けて
「こいづさ 私が嫁さ来る時
母ちゃんが繭から糸とって 織って
仕立ててでけた着物なの
もう着ないだげんどさ 元気出したい時に眺める
お守りなんだ」
そう言って見せてくれました
何十年もの時を超えて
かつて養蚕が盛んだった町の歴史
嫁入り支度の着物に込めた親の愛
それが私に伝わってきて
とても温かい気持ちになりました
でもこの着物はもう着る人がいない
これからどうなるんだろう
そう思ったのも覚えています
3月11日 東日本大震災が起きて
津波で多くの命が失われました
あのおばあさんの家も お守りだった着物も
波に飲み込まれてしまいました
私は支援物資の担当になり
毎日山のような段ボールに囲まれて
必死で復興業務に追われていました
そんな最中 父が病でこの世を去りました
人々が今まで積み重ねてきた暮らし
あの着物のように 心の支えだったものが
一瞬のうちに消えて
仕事も みんなが集まる場所もなくなりました
父はもう記憶の中だけの存在で
それすらも日ごとに薄れていく
頭ではね 誰のせいでもないし
もう起きちゃったことだから
しょうがないってわかるんですよね
でもやっぱり悔しくて
怒りとか悲しみとか色んな気持ちが毎日わいてきて
早く消えればいいのにと思うけど消えなくて
どうしていいかわからないまま過ごしていました
答えが出ないまま 夏には資料館に戻り
民俗調査を再開しました
しばらくたった頃 亘理では昭和の中頃まで
家族の着るものは その家の女性たちが
仕立てていたことを知りました
縫うことは女性にとって
生活の一部だったんです
そしてある農家で一つの巾着袋に出会いました
亘理に暮らす女性たちは
着物の残り布で仕立てておいた巾着袋に
一升のお米を入れて お祝いやお返し
手土産にしていました
小さな布も大切にして たくさん縫いためて
いつでもすぐに「ありがとね」って
気持ちを手渡していたんです
米粒が縫い目に入らないように裏地を付けて
口がしっかり閉まって中身がこぼれないように
紐は両引きにして
作り方にも渡す相手への配慮が
込められていました
「ふくろ」が訛って「ふぐろ」
「ふぐろ」は私に時間軸を超えて
自分とは異次元な生き方
感謝を形にする生き方を伝えてくれました
私は震災が起きて 父を病気で亡くすまで
安全で便利に暮らしていること
自分も家族も健康で生きていること
そんなの当たり前のことだと思っていました
失ってみて初めて
それがどんなにありがたいことだったのかに気付きました
いつでも伝えられるからと思って
父に「ありがとう」を言うことすら
後回しにしてきました
もう会いたくても会えなくなって
伝えたくても伝えられなくなって初めて
気持ちを形にするって
大事なんだなぁと気付いたから
「ふぐろ」のストーリーがとても心に残りました
亘理のちょっと昔の暮らしの中に
受け継ぎ 伝えていきたい生き方がある
こんなに素晴らしい価値がふるさとに埋もれている
そう思った時
これまで色あせて見えていたふるさとが
キラキラと輝き始めました
思いがけないところで 宝物を見つけました
「ふぐろ」に詰まった亘理の女性たちの
暮らしや生き方を
受け継ぎ 伝えたい
そのためにこの「ふぐろ」をもう一度甦らせ
新しい形で世に送り出したいと思いました
そうして誕生したのが
この新しい「FUGURO」です
たくさんの方に実際に使っていただけるように商品にして
亘理から広い地域に発信したいと思いました
被災して建物を取り壊すことになった
地元の呉服店から
着物の生地を譲り受けて
妹と友人と製作を開始しました
もう時代が変わって使う機会が少なくなった
古い「ふぐろ」を
今の時代に合うものにしようと
アイデアを出し合い 工夫を凝らしました
まず 名前をローマ字にしました
ストーリーはそのままに 新たにリメイクしたイメージを
持たせたかったからです
次はデザインです
裏地には鮮やかな色を組み合わせました
紐の先には可愛らしい飾りを付けて
現代のファッションにも合うものにしました
仕上がりにもこだわりました
ステッチをご覧下さい
直線には0.5mmのブレもありません
私たちに縫い物を教えてくださる地元の先生が
「縫い目見ると誰の仕事かわかるよ
生き様が表れるからね」
いつもそうおっしゃいます
まっすぐな縫い目には
「ぶれないものづくりをしていく」という
私たちの決意が込められています
お客様には 「丁寧で綺麗に仕上げてあって
使ってても見ててもとても気持ちがいい」
と言って頂きます
様々な素材の着物地を
ミシンを使って縫い上げていること
表地と裏地に合わせて２色の糸を使っていること
そんな細かいところにも気付いていただけた時は
とっても嬉しいです
FUGUROを作り続けて２年半
今 始めは予想もしていなかった良い循環が
三つも地域に生まれています
まず一つ目は 文化と技術の伝承の場が
生まれたことです
昔は当たり前だった「ふぐろ」のやり取りも
「ふぐろ」を縫う人も 今はもう少なくなって
このままでは亘理の返礼文化や縫製技術が
消えてしまいそうでした
地元の若い女性たちが おばあちゃんから
「小豆３粒包める布は
捨ててはあがんねよ［ダメだよ］」って
端切れも大切にすることを教わりながら
縫製の技術を学ぶことで
地域の文化や技術を次の世代に
受け継ぐことができるようになりました
二つ目は 被災地に新しいコミュニティができたことです
あの震災を経験してから
「何かあったらすぐ駆けつけられるように
子どものそばで働きたいんです」
そういうお母さんたちが増えました
女性が家事や育児
介護と両立しながら働く為には
働く時間を選べる仕組みが必要です
あの古い「ふぐろ」は元々 地元の女性が
家で空いた時間に手作業で作っていたもの
そこに女性のニーズに応じた
働き方のヒントがありました
自宅で自由な時間に「ふぐろ」を縫って
納品や研修の度に集まるうちに
震災で崩壊したコミュニティが仕事を通して
再び形になり始めました
今では作り手やその子どもたち
地域の人が集う交流の場になっています
三つ目 着物地の価値を高め 再び世に出す
アップサイクル文化を醸成していることです
元々あった古い「ふぐろ」は
着物地の残り布を再利用したものでした
私たちも今 全国から送られる着物地を
再利用しています
日本の衣料品のリサイクル率は20%以下と
あまり高くありません
そんな中で私たちは 昨年１年間で
タンスに眠る着物地 段ボールで314箱分
約2.3トン回収しました
それを亘理の女性たちの手で甦らせ
再び世に送り出しています
この度 FUGUROがスイスの高級腕時計メーカー
ジラール・ベルゴの
限定モデルパッケージに採用されました
また アメリカのハイエンドなアパレルブランド
トーマス・ワイルドとコラボ商品も製作
女性ファッション誌の25ansで誌上販売もしました
こうしてFUGUROのデザインやストーリーが
少しずつ海外でも認められるようになってきました
元々「ふぐろ」は
ある地域の一つの風習に過ぎないものですが
その中には 人と人をつなぐ
温かい心が詰まっています
それは世界に誇れる宝物だと思っています
こうして振り返ってみると
地域に好い循環をもたらし
様々な社会課題を解決するためのヒントは
すべて 古い農家で出会った
あの「ふぐろ」の中にあったのです
伝統や文化という地域に根付く価値
実はその中に 多くの問題を解決する鍵、力が
隠されているのかもしれません
物事には色んな面がありますよね
どの面から見るか どこに視点を当てるかで
見えるものが変わってきます
私は「ふぐろ」に出会ってから
ふるさとの良いところに目を向けられるようになりました
そこで生まれ育った自分の中に
しっかりと染み込んだ「亘理らしさ」も
以前は嫌いで 消してしまいたいと思ったけど
今は他の人には無い素敵な個性なんだと
思えるようになりました
そう思えるようになって
自分自身も 自分を取り巻く世界も
大きく変わったと思っています
WATALISの事務所には毎日のように
学校帰りの子どもたちが立ち寄ります
地域の伝統や文化に 身近に触れながら育つことは
やがてふるさとを誇らしく思う気持ちや
生まれ育ったこの地で生きていこうという想いにも
つながるはずです
母親の働く姿を通して
「本気で一生懸命働くことの尊さ」も
必ず伝わっていくと信じています
FUGUROに地域の伝統や文化を縫い込んで
地域の宝である「感謝を形にする生き方」を
お守りのように大切に
人から人へ たくさんの人へ
世界へ そして未来へ
受け継いでいきたいと思っています
どうもありがとうございます